foreign
Todd Smith I'm going to share with you
some information that has changed my
life it's about an individual named Dr
Joel Wallach he's a veterinarian who
worked with the famous Marlin Perkins of
the Mutual of Omaha Wild Kingdom I think
the thing that makes my view different
on health is that I'm a veterinarian as
well as a physician 23 years of
experience as a licensed physician
dealing with people or diseases worked
on a big Grant with the National
Institutes of Health and Marlon Perkins
from the old Mutual Omaha Wild Kingdom
days it was a seven and a half million
dollar Grant did over 20 000 autopsies
seventeen thousand five hundred
autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3 000 human beings for
comparison so it gives me a little
unique position in my training one of Dr
wallick's Landmark discoveries was this
the more complex the organism the more
nutrients it requires so we learned a
long time ago in the animal industry
that we could prevent and cure diseases
and animals with simple ill nutritional
formulas you can find these in little
Alfalfa pellets we've been so successful
at using this technique over the last 75
years we've eliminated about 900
different diseases in animals with
nutrition that still plague people so
what are the results of adding
nutritional supplements to animals feed
well let's take man's best friend for
example the dog have you ever heard of
dog years experts have said for years
that one dog year is equal to seven
human years that's because the average
dog in the 1960s lived to be 10 and the
average human was dying in their 70s you
know simple math seven to one today the
lifespan of dogs and cats is doubled
whereas the lifespan of humans is
unchanged and the only real difference
is that the animals are eating a perfect
diet fortified with over 40 minerals and
the humans are not and as a veterinarian
it always seemed odd to me that we would
use this technique for animals nobody
was doing for people
and I lectured to doctors for many years
during their continuing education
programs wrote scientific articles some
75 plus and I was never able to get
doctors interested in preventing and
curing diseases in people with
nutritional formulas and so I went back
to school and became a physician and
since 1978 I've been using these little
Veterinary nutritional formulas among
human patients and I can tell you that
the concept of preventing curing
diseases in animals of nutritional Farms
works the same in people have you ever
read the label of a can of human infant
formula have seen how few minerals there
are in it our dogs and cats are getting
over 40 minerals and our babies are
getting less than 12. it's pretty
frightening really I mean on that logic
you'd think dogs and cats are more
complex than humans
there are over 77 minerals naturally
occurring in the human body 77 60 of
them are essential for health you know
the fundamental problem is the
difference between vitamins and minerals
plants can manufacture vitamins but
they're dependent on the soil they grow
in for their minerals
plants can combine water and nutrients
from the soil through a process called
photosynthesis to produce vitamins and
amino acids minerals however cannot be
manufactured by the plant in essence the
minerals must be present in the soil to
be absorbed by the plant
another important thing to understand is
that minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket over the face of the Earth they
occur in veins like gold or silver and
tend to accumulate in locations such as
ancient riverbeds or glacial runoff
where the soils from multiple times and
locations have congregated well the
basic thing that people need to know
about supplementation is that
essential nutrients are called essential
nutrients for two reasons number one our
bodies can't manufacture them you must
consume them every day either is food or
supplements secondly if we don't consume
them every day we're going to get not
maybe perhaps could we're going to get
many horrible deficiency diseases many
of which are life-threatening
the problem we face today is that our
food is no longer grown in mineral-rich
areas large Farms that have been growing
crops for decades are now depleted of
these vital minerals Farmers replace
only what is necessary to make sure
their crops will grow take a look at
this study from the USDA
you can see that the drop in Mineral and
vitamin content in our food has been
significant we can see it in corn onions
broccoli strawberries and many other
fruits and vegetables
if the minerals are not in our food we
need to supplement in order to maintain
good health
look at how much we could reduce
diseases if we were just taking the
minimum recommendations of vitamins and
minerals each day according to the USDA
estimate one day Dr Joel Walla came to
my office
and place the bottle
on my desk and said these are
plantarized minerals I want you to
examine those well so we did and we've
found some very very interesting results
that made me really convinced that this
is a great product not only does it
contain a great many elements it also
contains them in a form
which makes them substantially active
the bottle that Dr Wallach gave to Dr
shrauser turned out to be plant-derived
colloidal minerals from an ancient plant
deposit found in the pristine mountains
of Utah far away from pollution and
human contact these ancient plants lived
at a time and in a location where more
than 70 minerals naturally occurred in
the soils and were therefore taken up in
the plants that grew there these
mineral-rich plants having never
fossilized or turned to stone have been
entombed and preserved for hundreds of
thousands of years there are many
traditional stories which have been told
about these Mountain Springs
American Indians speak of the magical
healing benefits they experience when
drinking from them early Prospectors
included stories in their journals of
how these Waters helped ease joint pain
and other illnesses
modern science and Manufacturing have
been able to better explain the Amazing
Stories stemming from these Mountain
Streams
bottom line we need to get our minerals
from Plants doctors Wallach and Mala
knew this and felt compelled to get this
message out in fact that's why Dr
Wallach went back to school and
practiced privately for over 12 years
treating human patients with these
animal formulas giving them the
nutrition that they needed and after
thousands and thousands of people having
positive results they felt now they need
to take this message to the masses they
need to reach more people and they turn
to the power of Word of Mouth they
formed a company American Longevity with
the purpose of changing lives
American Longevity is a flourishing
multi-million dollar company passionate
about spreading the message of good
health they've designed an extensive
line of nutritional products based upon
the science of plant-derived minerals
they put together a team of scientists
and doctors respected around the world
that are recommending these products to
their patients for good health all the
members in our family have found very
good results using these products we
have a daughter and after starting her
on the recommended products about two
weeks into it she was a different child
it was just night and day all of a
sudden she was sweet and kind and loving
and she took the rock out from under her
pillow that she kept there to throw at
the other kids in the night if they made
her mad
before using Sam cream I've had a whole
lot of aching joints and pain
I'm 41 years of age
and the thing about that is ever since I
started taking the CM cream I've been
pain-free
that makes all the difference in the
world
my husband introduced me to these
products and I've been taking them now
for two years and I've noticed a real
difference in my health and I have a lot
more energy and overall Vitality I
outfit people on hunting trips and pack
trips
into the high mountains of Utah and
Wyoming in my writing it's very labor
intensive
and my knees were wearing out and they
were hurting my shoulders were hurting
my thumb was hurting but my arm was
hurting my back was hurting well I got
on this on February the 7th and I'd say
in three months time
I had no more pain
I had all kinds of energy I'm 75 years
old I'm doing work I'm a 50 year old man
it's awesome what American lungivity has
done for my body I just got traded to
Atlanta I had a multitude of injuries I
just came from making All-Star team but
I wasn't able to play an All-Star team
because I had broken my wrist I used the
product came back the next year and had
a great year stayed healthy for like
three straight years without any issues
so I was working at a fast food
restaurant I was overweight I had knee
problems being overweight I couldn't
exercise I was eating all of the wrong
foods and so it caused a whole lot of
problems I was introduced to the
products and I lost the weight I changed
my eating habits so I changed my diet
and I have taken care of the knee
problems and I've been able to really
change my whole life with the American
Longevity products American Longevity is
about educating people and we're now in
many countries it takes a lot of people
to pass on this message as passionate as
I am about it one person can't do this
and so we've decided to reward people
financially for helping us spread the
message and it's very exciting how many
people take on the responsibility of
passing the message and we pay very well
we like to help people not only with
their health but also their Financial
Health and well-being and we're very
very proud of American Longevity for
being able to pull this off so we
actually pay out more than any other
network marketing company out there in
theory and in reality I
when
I hear that the lake is planning to
introduce this business to Japan I was
not successful in any other programs but
in this longevity people are more
willing to listen and my downline is
still a growing and I'm very successful
it's a huge opportunity for people that
want to build a business off of
providing high quality good products
that people see benefit and value in
that's really a very rewarding part of
my job is to see those ideas implemented
into a not only a usable product but a
product that people then see value in
and then we get testimonials back on
those products from the time they went
from being just an idea to an actual
product to people receiving benefit and
Reporting back results and so that's the
most rewarding part for me but also for
our Distributors you know I hear
countless stories from Distributors that
love getting those testimonials and the
feedback from their customers and people
they know they've helped this company
was established by Distributors again
for distributors so we have their needs
in mind and we know what they go through
out in the field to promote the products
and so we're very receptive to their
input and ideas because it's on a
downline system people can utilize you
know a star athlete being involved with
the product in order to sell rebound and
you know create a business off of it I
first got involved with the Australian
longevity by taking their colloidal
minerals
from then I started becoming a
distributor
now I have people in five different
countries Distributing for me
Australian longevity has allowed me to
choose what I want to do not what I have
to do you need to get involved in
American Longevity if you want to do
something more if you want to do more
than just make money it's a way to make
a difference it's something you can sink
your teeth into the products are there
the financial support is there the
Integrity is there and to me if you
don't have integrity you have nothing
it's given me the opportunity
but not only that it gave us a Financial
Freedom to take a two-year retirement
and go travel 48 of the states with Dan
myself and our son Zachary
and our check has increased every month
in our retirement and I don't know
anyone else our age I can do that I
needed to do something that will Empower
me for my future and I am so glad I did
if people knew what they're missing
then they wouldn't miss it they would do
whatever they could
to make this work whatever it is as far
as help goes and as far as making extra
money a month you know it's it's not
that hard I'm telling you I live in
Washington now Washington DC and let me
tell you people there are stressed out
High Strung and about ready to break and
it just amazes me they go to work at
seven o'clock in the morning they get
home at seven or eight o'clock at night
they are totally stressed out and so
many people that are like that all
across the country
if they just knew what a residual income
could do
they would do whatever it took
to build a residual income and at the
same time help people
truth is I'm a distributor of American
Longevity and have been for eight years
I joined the company back when my wife
and I found out we were going to have
triplets and I had to quit my job to
stay in school
I was introduced to this company because
of the products because they'd helped my
parents so much with their health they
told me they said Todd if you can find a
way to make money with this you've got
yourself an incredible business because
these products are for real and they
really work
these products in this company have
provided us some incredible health
benefits as a family they provided us
some Financial opportunities and things
that we just never dreamed about a
lifestyle that we thoroughly enjoy
I hope you've enjoyed this information
I've enjoyed sharing it with you and I
hope you'll join us with our American
Longevity family
thank you